this is a green winged macaw  aren't our colours stunning  so stunning that the illegal parrot  trade has caused its population to  decrease heavily in recent years  the green-winged macaw is considered one  of the largest macaw parrots but also  one of the most docile  it is commonly referred to as the gentle  giant  they are very sweet affectionate and  friendly with both humans and other  birds  maybe because of these easy going ways  these birds have been known to live  upwards of 80 years  they favor tropical forests swamps and  savannas  their habitat ranges from panama in the  north across south america down to  paraguay in the south they feed on  fruits seeds berries and nuts  their incredibly powerful beaks are  capable of opening the hardest of nuts  and seeds  along with poaching their habitat has  been shrinking considerably and in  certain parts where they used to be  plentiful they've become harder and  harder to find  this is the green winged macaw  you